welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Pablo c'mon Yvette's a postdoctoral
fellow in the political science
department at Yale University he
specializes in the political theory of
human rights and humanitarianism
professor c'mon Yvette's has written
articles and edited volumes on
transitional justice post-war
reconstruction and the regulation of
warfare and he's currently working on a
book project on the history of the idea
of post-war justice today we talked with
Professor Cal man of it's about the
research he's done on reparations for
war damages welcome professor Camlann
events thank you Mary let's begin with
what led you to do this kind of research
alright so I I was initially attracted
by the idea of transitional justice and
transitional justice is a term used to
refer to actions taken to come to terms
with the past al-qaeda context of a
regime transition so a well known cases
Argentina there was a military junta in
Argentina from 76 to 83 and at the end
of that one time when the hunter fail a
president in sri raghavan scene came to
power who was democratically elected and
president Alfonsin had to decide what to
do with a legacy of massive atrocities
particular disappearances extrajudicial
killings are done by the military during
the authoritarian regime so he had to
make this really hard decision of what
to do about that and he was really
facing a really interesting and
difficult dilemma between on the one
hand securing the transition making sure
that the military would play along and
surrender power but on the other hand he
had to be a defender of the rule of law
and democracy and he had to show all
citizens that nobody was going to be
above the law including the military so
he had to prosecute
so military but perhaps not all of them
so there was this really difficult
political balance between securing the
transition peace order and justice so
that led me to think more generally
about the question of how or how can we
say that the end of a given war in this
case a dirty war is just or acceptable
or or in some sense decent and that's
the general question that I want to
address and i realize i discovered that
this question has a very long history
and it has not always been the case as
it is today that that there's a lot of
insistence on prosecutions and
reparations and truth commissions and
these are really a very strong movement
for coming to terms with the past now
but if you look at that historically
well it's it's a rather new thing okay
in your paper you look I get guess at
the last 20 years or so and that this is
a time when people really begin to look
at war reparations talk about your paper
and give us a little bit of an overview
and what you're looking at right so yeah
so this paper is not historical and I
start with what I take to be something
like a legal factor some people say a
soft legal fact but it is a declaration
that the UN General Assembly made in
2005 on the right to a remedy and to
reparations and this is a right that
supposed to apply in virtue of
international human rights instruments
and and the UN chartering in a way to
victims of massive violations of human
rights and it's a very ambitious a
statement of the duty to repair it
includes not only actual harms but also
losses of opportunity and earning that
has been missed because of the
violations so it's only counterfactual
losses also counterfactual losses that
are included and so I took that as a
starting point and then contrasted that
with the reality of war which is a lot
of destruction institutional weakness in
the States very scarce resources like in
terms of officers and budget and money
and just capacity state capacity and I
just said well these
Miriam bishops plan that they are
guideline that the UN General Assembly
is producing doesn't match the reality
of a war and so I would let the thing
okay so how can we justify how much can
we justify a riot of reparations in the
context of the aftermath of a war when
you say it doesn't address the realities
of the war what do you mean by that well
basically that there are a lot of
victims of harm director in the red card
much more than could be repaired via the
resourcer with the resources that the
state has and also institutional
weakness so states at the end of our are
often well they have in ravaged by war
and there are institutionally very weak
so not capable of implementing any or
very ambitious reparations project so if
you take that into a car does real
constraints political constraints on
state action then you have to give up
some of these very high expectations at
the General Assembly's is influencing
okay and then in your paper you you talk
about normative accounts of corrective
justice so what do you look at in terms
of that right so so what I do is I take
that this legal fact which is a
statement of principle and then I
contrast that with theories of the
Justice of preparations are in
corrective justice and I look at three
different approaches one is a classical
standard leveler approach which which
says that reparations should be given in
order to protect the value of individual
autonomy and the idea is that if you get
reparations fairly soon and proportional
to the harm you have suffer then that
would protect any kind it would minimize
the level of diameter or how upset your
plans are by the harm so the idea is the
quicker you get reparations on day the
more equal depressions are to the
harmless offer the better you can carry
on with life you one half your so that's
individual autonomy and what I do about
or what I say from that standpoint is
often harm is the rule rather than the
exception in
our cases so a lot of people if not a
majority of people have been harmed so
it is impossible to recover the status
quo ante situation for people it is
impossible to uphold autonomy in the way
that this liberal theory wants to uphold
it so we have to in a way accept the
reality tragic reality of war and the
destruction and the irreparable really
effective war in people's lives and
perhaps instead of looking back coming
to terms via reparations look forward I
think okay what's necessary to for
people to read recreate their lives in a
decent more less egalitarian way so
that's what I do especially in the in
the second approach that I look at which
is a theorist property which is again
very influential in the liberal
tradition goes back to John Locke and
and what I argue there is exactly that
is that if the most or a very plausible
theory of property would tell us
prioritize giving everybody an equal
opportunity to reconstruct their lives
in the aftermath of war not so much I
make sure that past entitlements are
absurd or respected but more give
everyone a chance to start a new life
after the war on equal terms and finally
the third approach I look at is the idea
of reestablishing a well functioning
market this is not really a theory of
justice is more a problem of
coordination or institutional creation
of a well institutionalized market and
one finding that I have that I think
it's interesting is that this is the
account that gives more weight to a
program of reparations and the idea is
not so much about justice but more about
social coordination in the sense of if
we want a well functioning market after
a word then we need to have a focal
point that tell tells us who has what at
the end of a word who is the owner of
what good and and so the pass provides
that focal point in a way we know who
owns what because that's the way it used
to be but the claim is not really about
justice but more about coordination
there are
aspects of justice involved if we
believe that markets are good for people
is a good way of distributing resources
are producing more but really it's about
knowing who owns what in order to move
forward okay and what are you suggesting
in terms of reparations and the best way
to move forward and and in particular
can you use your theory and in terms of
a particular war well so basically I
guess the main message is our healthy
doses of skepticism about these like
backward-looking emphasis in recent
discourse there are good reasons to be
less focus on the past and more focus on
the future on reconstruction and that
may mean sacrificing past entitlements
but what I'm arguing is that that's not
that doesn't seem so serious or so grave
morally and other I think important our
contribution that I want to make is to
look at were at the tragedy of a war
like a lot of these discs or sometimes
seems to have this hope of erasing the
effects of a word going back before the
time of the war and well that's not
possible and so it's there's a message
of also just so very accepting the
losses and finally there is also this
connection between reparations and
private property and the market which is
there but it's not often made explicit
and I think it's a really interesting
connection and it's something worth
discussing and thinking about if a
private property regime is the only
acceptable way that a country should
adopt at the end of a word maybe there's
collective property or traditional uses
of property and those are worth thinking
about also now I turn to like actual
cases so there are two cases i guess i
would talk about it okay good it's good
just to talk specifics right because it
gives people a good idea really of what
you're what you're talking about right
so the first one is Colombia and I'm
from Colombia and this is really the
case that got me started with all these
so recently Colombia has passed a very
ambitious land restitution law in
Congress
and there is there's been a huge problem
of internal displacement in the country
about between 3.5 and 5 million people
has been internally displays which is a
good chunk of the whole population about
ten percent and how has it been
displaced so basically so there's been
an armed conflict going on for decades
okay and as it's still going on yeah yes
okay and one of the strategy of the
armed actors has been to push people
outside of their region so thinking that
they're supporting the other side or
just because they want to appropriate
the land or people just run away because
they're scared so it may be intentional
or unintentional but I'm sorry the fact
of this country has of these warrants or
it has been huge massive displacement or
a wave of forced migration to the series
from the countryside to the city and now
the the government and Congress they
want to implement this law to give back
the land the people who have lost it and
in a way create incentives for them to
return to the countryside I'm sorry but
if the war is still going on this armed
conflict is still still going on why did
the people move from the country to the
city is it because it's safer in the
city okay so if they move back to the
country and the conflict is still going
on how is that going to help them it's
not clear all right so one well perhaps
the main objection or preoccupation with
this law is how are you going to protect
these people if they returned because
the war is not over indeed and is so the
government is making efforts but it's
very clear that the it still doesn't
have the power the capacity to really
guarantee security for returnees so
there is that there's also the fact that
people may not have jobs when they come
back so irrigation systems roads markets
in the in the countryside maybe may have
been lost or destroyed or sure
eliminated for by the war and so there's
this very hard dilemma like should the
government invest in returning for these
people or should it rather create
opportunities for them to resettle in
cities and become urban
so I so that's a case and what my theory
would say is something like well they
should be given the opportunity but the
emphasis on returning perhaps shouldn't
be as high and perhaps there should be a
sober acceptance of the weakness of the
government and the factor of the state
really and the fact that they cannot
really create order and security in the
countryside and then a second base
option would be to provide them with all
the resources necessary to make a living
in the city so it's except they you know
the sad fact that the government of the
state has no control in all areas and
give the best possible opportunity to
people who are in the cities are
settlers to become established and have
a good life there now how did your
theory work when it's not all taking
place in one country where it's two
different countries warn ya so that's in
these in this particular paper I don't
look at that case I keep it all within
one state because the international case
is hard because there is the issue of
interstate reparations and right now so
there is some principles that say that
an aggressor state has to pay
reparations to a and I did it to the
injured state but that kind of
consideration I'm not really looking at
in excess okay and did you have another
country you could cite in terms of
specifics right so there's another
interesting case which is east timor ah
and what has happened in st mary's is
really it's a really complicated
situation because so ii steamer was a
portuguese colony until they I remember
like early 70s when the Portuguese left
and Indonesia invaded the country and
there was this occupation that was
Indonesia claimed that they had just not
incorporated East Timor to their state
but steamer the st mary's didn't accept
that and the international community
didn't accept that and so there was a
referendum in thing two thousand but
didn't a mass genocide took place on
that country crabs not well so what
happened is that there was this
referendum and they
st marys overwhelmingly said we want
independence and when the Indonesians
were living they destroy everything
there was this huge especially material
destruction but also massive rapes and
killings and was a really burberry way
of leaving the country and this tomorrow
is already a very poor place so it was
they among other things they destroy the
land registry so nobody knew who so and
then there is a really difficult
challenge withdraw so there's a UN
administration came in to basically
perform as a state as a government and
they had to decide how are we going to
repair to give people back their land
but the difficulty is that do we look
all the way back to the Portuguese our
times of you know when the winds were
the Masters or do we look at a land
owning when the Indonesians were
occupying or do we look at traditional
relationship with the Lancer three
different layers of title and basically
they don't know and there's been a lot
of or some work trying to go back to
Portuguese times but that can be seems
counterintuitive and necessary really
and so my take on that would be no
emphasize the present and try to create
conditions that would make people who
are there now have a good life and again
don't do don't look to the past so but
let me ask you this if i was living in
East Timor and I had 20 acres of land
for instance and my neighbor only had 10
acres of land how do you care for that
situation because if now we're just
going we're not we're trying to make
everything not go back as far how can I
be assured as the one who owns the more
land that I will still have that or does
that just go out the window and everyone
will be given an equal amount of land
well so there's there's a word that if
you do that like equalize land
completely you would create a lot of a
lot of uncertainty and K or some people
it will be very hard to know what what
you have and that goes back to this idea
of restoring the market
if you do that then you undermine the
market and you will create a lot of
resistance probably and for people who
own more right so probably you cannot do
that really so there's a constraint on
that and I think the constraint comes
from they need to have some level of
certainty but on the other hand if you
have 20 acres your neighbor has 10 and
you decided to leave the country you
went let's say you went to Europe to
Portugal I don't know and you haven't
been back in years and then you you hear
that the Indonesians have left and you
say well maybe I should go go back we
claim my land I think if you have been
away for so long and you are not living
in each team and you just want to have
the land in order to I do not rent it or
something then I would tell your claim
is weak and maybe your neighbor should
have more land because he's there and
he's working maybe other people who are
landless should have your land because
they are willing and able to work it so
there are some so I proposal I more
nuanced palace in look like a blanket
you know notification of all property
and everything will have everyone will
have the same but it's more like what's
your commitment was what is your present
situation how how are you what are you
planning to do with this land I think
those things are important okay tell me
how the work you've done on war
reparations fits into your larger book
project so it's interesting because in a
way one important component of this work
I'm doing is to trace the history of
these idea of war reparations and so I
beginning the in the 16th century
basically there's this Spanish natural
law theories who were the ones who
basically began to think about Jose war
and what is it just war they also
thought about what is a post-war sorry a
post yeah I just paused for a context
and they said that in in the case of a
war if your property or yourself happy
have suffered harm or damage then you
had to put up with it it was bad luck
and the burden the burden of
reconstructing or fixing that should be
on you like there is no duty to repair
in this
Dave there is talk of a duty to repair
later more in the 18th century and it's
put under the umbrella of social
solidarity there should be a solidarity
in the state said such such that if
someone had software harm then fellow
citizens will help and it's inverted as
a you can see it as an insurance
mechanism more or less as when a natural
catastrophe hits their solidarity and
you help I mean you were you were spare
but another one was not yes that's a
good example let me just clarify you're
still talking about within an individual
country not countries against countries
well in that case if so to the extent
that a country let's say in an
international war if an aggressor candle
is that you know doesn't have the means
to fully repair all the damage is that
it has caused then there has to be some
level of reconstruction inside the state
so even if there's some level of
international reparations probably you
need to resort to Social Solidarity of
some sort because just because the
destruction out matches the ability to
to reconstruct lino states are typically
don't have those resources or worse
typically and more destructive than that
so even in that case there is probably
an appeal to social solidarity but in
the in the eighteen and nineteen century
was like a week principal it's not they
typically say this is not part of
international law it's more a duty of
you know morality and it should be done
to put that kind of to do that in
international law and to say it should
go as far as lost opportunities that's a
really new development and it's much
more ambitious than the people in the
eighteen and nineteen century where and
and I am actually a bit skeptical I
think they're there are two ambitions
there are two utopians if you want and
probably something closer to the
nineteen 19th century model seems more
plausible and acceptable more realistic
right now in doing your research are in
addition to the actual political
theories around reparations are you
looking at what actually happened in
each country and incorporating that into
your work
well I so far not as much I've been
looking more the theories but I want to
do that I want to look because that
would be very interesting to see what
the theory are and what actually was the
price was right so it does that's part
of mine okay well good luck with that
and thank you so much for being here
with us and sharing center out some of
your work thank you for more information
about professor come on of it please
visit our webpage at yale edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you